FEDERAL PROSECUTOR ELIE HONIG.
EVERY AMERICAN CITIZEN HAS A HAS
EVERY RIGHT TO INSERT THEIR
FIFTH AMENDMENT RIGHT.
LISTEN.
>> HAVE YOUR STAFF TAKING THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT, TAKING THE
FIFTH!
SO THEY ARE NOT PROSECUTED.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE MAN THAT SET
UP THE ILLEGAL SERVER, TAKING
THE FIFTH, I THINK IT'S
SDRASFUL.
YOU SEE THE MOB TAKES THE FIFTH.
IF YOU'RE INNOCENT, WHY ARE YOU
TAKING THE FIFTH AMENDMENT?
>> THAT IS DONALD TRUMP, THE
POLITICIAN.
ELIE, FROM A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE,
HIS AND SAID DON'T ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS.
WALK US THROUGH WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE HYPOCRISY
IS SHOCKING.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP'S RIGHT HE
CAN TAKE THE FIFTH THE SAME AS
ANYONE ELSE CAN.
IMPORTANT TO KNOW IN A CIVIL
LAWSUIT IN NEW YORK STATE, IF
SOMEBODY TAKES THE FIFTH THAT
CAN ACTUALLY BE USED AGAINST
THEM.
THE JURY CAN DRAW WHAT IS CALLED
AN ADVERSE INFERENCE MEANING THE
JURY IN A CIVIL CASE CAN ASSUME
THE WORSE WHAT HIS TESTIMONY
MIGHT HAVE BEEN BUT CANNOT BE
USED AGAINST HIM IN ANY WAY IN A
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
I THINK IT'S WORTH NOTING HERE,
JOHN.
LETITIA JAMES HAS POLITICIZED
THIS.
THEY HAS FUND-RAISED ON IT SO
THAT IS NOT A RIDICULOUS FEAR
FOR HIM TO HAVE.
>> IT'S NOT RIDICULOUS BECAUSE
OF THAT, YOU'RE RIGHT.
AND PROSECUTORS SHOULD KNOW WHEN
THEY TAKE THE JOB, THEY NEED TO
BE MORE CAREFUL ABOUT TALKING
ABOUT POLITICS.
JUST QUICKLY FOR OUR VIEWERS WHO
MIGHT BE CONFUSED BECAUSE THEY
HEAR ABOUT THE RAID AT THE
PRESIDENT'S -- SEARCH AT THE
PRESIDENT'S MAR-A-LAGO HOUSE AND
THE GEORGIA INVESTIGATIONS AND
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
WHAT IS AT STAKE IN THIS CIVIL
INVESTIGATION IN NEW YORK?
>> THERE IS A LOT TO SORT OUT.
THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION OF THE
FINANCIAL PRACTICES OF THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION PRIMARY BEFORE
DONALD TRUMP EVEN BECAME
PRESIDENT P.M. THE KEY
ALLEGATION HERE IS THAT THE
ORGANIZATION WOULD INTENTIONALLY
OR DEFLATE THE VALUE OF ITS
ASSETS IN ORDER TO CHEAT ON
TAXES AND INSURANCE.
HERE IS THE BIG PICTURE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE LEGAL PRESSURES
TRUMP IS FACING.
TWO DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
PROBES.
ONE INVOLVING CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
THE OTHER JANUARY 6th.
THERE IS ALSO THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATION INTO HIS
ROLE IN THE INSURRECTION.
THEN IN GEORGIA TRUMP'S INFAMOUS
FINE THE VOTES PHONE CALL, THE
CRUX OF AN ELECTION INTERFERENCE
CASE.
THEN THERE IS HIS TAXES, HIS
FINANCES.
THERE ARE THREE SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS HERE AND, TODAY,
THERE WAS A DEPOSITION INVOLVING
THE CIVIL PROBE IN NEW YORK.
THAT IS WHERE WE WANT TO BEGIN
WITH CNN'S  KARA.
WOULD THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ANSWER QUESTIONS OR WOULD HE
ASSERT THE FIFTH?
HE CHOSE THE LATTER.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
THAT IS RIGHT.
THAT WAS THE BIG QUESTION THIS
MORNING.
DONALD TRUMP ARRIVED HERE ABOUT
FOUR HOURS AGO.
HE IS IN THE BUILDING JUST OVER
MY SHOULDER AT THE NEW YORK
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE WHERE
HE IS UNDERGOING THIS
DEPOSITION.
HE HAS BEEN THERE FOR A COUPLE
OF HOURS NOW.
HE IS ASSERTING THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT.
HE SAID HE WASN'T GOING TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS BECAUSE HE SAID
THE NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL
LETITIA JAMES, A DEMOCRAT,
SAYING HER INVESTIGATION WAS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED AND WHAT
SOLIDIFIED HIS DECISION WAS THE
FBI SEARCH WARRANT ON HIS HOME
IN FLORIDA AT MAR-A-LAGO ON
MONDAY.
HE SAID THAT THAT MADE IT CLEAR
TO HIM THAT HE DIDN'T WANT TO
TESTIFY AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
UNDER OATH.
IN A VERY LENGTHY STATEMENT, HE
MADE ALL OF THESE ALLEGATIONS
BUT I'LL READ YOU A PART OF IT
IN WHICH HE SAID, QUOTE.
WE HAVE HEARD HIM SAY WITCH HUNT
MANY TIMES ABOUT ALL OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW LONG HE WILL BE
IN THAT ROOM ANSWERING QUESTIONS
OR NOT ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
HIS SON ERIC TRUMP SAT FOR A
DEPOSITION IN 2020.
HE ASSERTED THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
MORE THAN 500 TIMES SO HE COULD
BE IN THERE QUITE A WHILE.
HIS OTHER SON AND IVANKA TRUMP
TESTIFIED THE PAST FEW WEEKS AN
THEY ANSWERED QUESTIONS AS PART
OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
THEY ARE LOOKING INTO WHETHER
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION HAD
MISLED ITS LENDERS AND INSURERS
AND EVEN TAX AUTHORITIES BY
PROVIDING THEM MISLEADING
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS.
WHAT WAS TRUMP'S ROLE IN THIS
INVESTIGATIONS AND DID HE HELP
PREPARE ANY EVALUATIONS ON THEM?
HE IS NOT ANSWERING THOSE
QUESTIONS TODAY.
>> IT'S INTERESTING AND WE WILL
SEE WHAT ELSE COMES OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.